le premier concours international de
roses d'orléans s'est tenue en 1959 dans
une roseraie spécialement aménagé pour
l'événement
au coeur du jardin des plantes et c'est
dans le même lieu que se tient sa 61e
édition en fin de saison et c'est
justement sa particularité c'est le
dernier concours de rose de cette région
d'europe est donc présente des rosiers
remontants donc qu'ils ont vécu deux
saisons en fait la première saison
2 juin et on les juge seulement
maintenant ça nous permet d'avoir une
véritable bonne appréciation de la
qualité du rosier c'est un jury
international présidé par l'agronome et
journaliste jean paul collaert qui tout
l'après-midi aura à juger de la qualité
des rosiers présentait alors on a
d'abord une note générale sur l'état
général
est-ce que c'est à rosicky et pêchue
qu'à la forme qu'il ya beaucoup de tiges
bien répartie beaufeuillage st on veut
plus de rosiers malades deuxième note
c'est la rose elle-même l'acheteur
qu'est-ce qu'elle a d'original
qu'est ce qu'elle a de d'émotion parce
qu'il faut qu'une rose est de
transmettre une émotion et puis
troisième note parfum qui est comme très
important tout le monde a envie se
penche pour sentir une rose
voyez ce rosier jaune par exemple déjà
c'est un vrai rosiers grimpants parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a eu tendance à mettre
sur le marché des rosiers qui étaient
moyennement grimpons il s'arrêtait à 1
mètre 80 et ça s'arrêtait là là il a
vraiment de la vigueur il est beau le
feuillage est sain on voit à peine
quelques petites tâches les fleurs bas
ma foi si on aime les rosiers jaune on a
tout ce qu'il faut un petit parfum
discret mais sympathique un peu de savon
est un petit peu original et je pense
qu'il est assez florifères parce qu'on
voit encore des boutons qui vont
s'ouvrir
donc pour le reste de la saison quand
trois variétés de rosiers sont ainsi
présentés 39 ans buisson et quatre ans
rosiers grimpants certains viennent
d'allemagne d'autres du danemark de
suisse
et bien sûr de france le mieux noté
recevra le soir même une rose d'or parmi
d'autres prix dont celui de
l'environnement
et c'est là aussi une particularité du
concours orléanais